good morning believe nation today's
message is think about the future over
to you Rick Ross I wake up every mood
this recipe ve go you know I just felt
everybody's situation is unique I feel
everybody situation is different you
know the most definitely you gotta um
gotta think of tomorrow you know not
just today so the decisions you making
sure most definitely consider you know
in a long term and I think that's the
difference you know let's not be so
short term on everything now now now
let's kind of just cut it let's be
patient and on a lot of different things
and most definitely invested as one of
them this is a great message and what I
wanted to add to it was that you can't
just think about the future you got to
actually take action on it because I
find too many entrepreneurs just have
these dreams for what you want to do
these plans what you want to do is 10
year plan for where you're going to go
and you never actually execute against
it right crunch down on those timelines
that 10-year plan that you want to get
accomplished do it now one year six
months three months put the action
immediately stop saying one day I'm
going to do this and make that one day
today I was talk with a young
entrepreneur this morning and his dream
is to go surfing before he goes to work
at his company and it's like one day I'm
going to make that happen go make it
happen now there's nothing to hold you
back from moving to California and doing
that right now this plenty of wannabe
aspiring actors who move to Hollywood
every day to chase their dreams there's
immigrants who come to this country with
nothing in their pockets to chase their
dreams and do something you can move to
California and start your dream of
surfing and then running your business
there's nothing that holds you back
except the story that you're telling
yourself you need to eliminate the one
day thought that mentality those two
words should be stricken forbidden
eliminated from your vocabulary now you
may be thinking what about money I don't
enough money to go and do that and chase
my dream but you know what there's
people who have less money than you less
education in you who didn't have the
right connections and and the right
parents and who are weighed less
privileged than you who are off chasing
the dreams who are off taking action
they're investing their hustle their
drive their energy and heart to making
their dreams come true while you're
telling yourself a story as to why it
can't happen the number one thing that
people talk about when they're on their
deathbeds is that they wish that they
took more risk that they wish they
believe themselves and they followed
their dreams and they arrived there on
their deathbed because that 10-year plan
of there is that one day future of
theirs never came to fruition because
ten years next year we're still ten
years the next he was still ten years
and one day was never a day of the week
that was priority for them so don't be
that person don't be on your deathbed
wishing that you would take an action on
your big dreams yes is important to
think about the future but you have to
take action on question of the day this
is going deep I want to know what the
one-day story is that you're telling
yourself the thing that you'll do one
day when the conditions are perfect what
is that leaving the comments below I'm
curious to find out thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events press 0 this race to keep eagle